Film Courage: What do you think makes you
different from the other screenwriters who
have come to Hollywood during the same time,
where you've been able to make a career at
this and possibly they haven't?
Jim Agnew, Screenwriter: I think understanding
the business because I was in the business
part of it first and producing and just knowing
how distribution works knowing what they know,
how actors sell films and things like that
because just you can kind of can filter it
through a different kind of lens where it's
like okay this is what people are looking
for because I've been to AFM [American Film
Market], I've been to Cannes, I've been to
Sundance on the business side of it so you
see all those posters, you see what kind of
movies are trying to put together and you
also see how many movies are being put together
you know it's like astronomical if you go
to AFM how many films are tens of thousands
of them and maybe you know a finite number
of those get made but you see a recurring
theme and you kind of understand how these
people work you know and it just depends on
on what kind of like you know level you're
at to studio level is completely different
i'm talking more about the indie world you
know but breaking into the studio world is
very difficult as well he said you have to
work your way up on that so i think that gave
me advantage that was just understanding um
the business and i can also put myself in
the mindset of a producer when i'm writing
something and i know okay the producer's not
gonna like that but they'll like this so that
helps where someone else may have come out
but they had no prior film industry experience
and so even though it's a very personalized
story it just won't work because it doesn't
tick these different boxes exactly and like
who's going to be like like we talk about
the the movie about your uncle who runs a
you know a pawn shop you know what actor is
dying to play that part that can finance a
film and then that turns into a whole other
conversation altogether because there's so
few actors at certain levels that can finance
a film that's the reason you see so many Bruce
Willis movies, Nick Cage movies, you know
John Travolta movies there's not a big pool
of people that can justify people spending
five 10 20 million dollars so that's part
understanding that's a big part of it as well
how does genre factor in getting a movie made
well this is a very important thing to remember
is that the reason you see so many action
films on uh Netflix and things like that it's
because action films and thrillers translate
internationally if you want to make a comedy
and it's a comedy about a bunch of kids in
New Jersey and and you know they're going
through their last summer before they graduate
high school and there's a bunch of jokes about
you know American kids in jersey that's not
going to translate in like Malaysia they're
not going to understand it so those movies
have no very little international value but
now action and thrillers sci-fi and horror
is like an international language that's why
you see so many of those films because they
can sell not only in America but all around
the world and that's also something you need
to keep in mind if you have this small intimate
you know film that you want to make about
the screenplay that's about you know four
sisters in Ohio and it's a comedy drama it's
like you've got a very small audience for
that so you know that's why producers don't
like things like that and that's why when
you look you can see so many of those action
thrillers on Netflix because they make money
internationally but what if it's in someone's
heart i don't mean to sound so cheesy but
what if it's what if it's in someone's DNA
that they just want to make a coming-of-age
story and to them they have to get that story
out there and they want to finish it well
i mean if if you're a screenwriter like that
that's got that story i think you should become
a filmmaker if it's that that story is like
figure out a way to make the ten 10 000 version
of that or the 50 000 version of it and make
it you know that's that's the thing is like
you've probably got a better chance of like
cobbling together your friends and making
a decent movie of that and maybe getting in
some film festivals getting noticed like that
than just sending your script out to people
so that's what i would suggest you know now
that takes money and resources but if that's
your passion project you know spend a few
years you know putting together all those
resources or figure out a way to shoot it
there's you know there's great films that
have been made for ten thousand dollars you
know you just have to understand how filmmaking
works that's a whole nother conversation altogether
but you can do it i think we've already touched
on this but is it correct that you didn't
get an agent until you sold your first script
i had a manager and then um when we sold the
second script there was an article about the
Hollywood reporter and then literally that
next morning there was like 10 agents called
now you don't always need to here's the thing
is agents are great but they're not a magic
bullet for your career either you know they
do things for you and managers do too but
you have to do a lot on your own you have
to meet producers you have to get out there
you have to do things um and i think actually
part of that what got the ball rolling on
that that film was was people really dug the
script but i think the reason we got involved
with those producers because i'm forgetting
some of this stuff is a friend of mine who
had worked with me on a film that i had produced
who was a production coordinator was now working
for them as a development exec and she was
like you should check out their script so
it all kind of tied together from one thing
into another so it's all about those relationships
again what was the title of the article don't
remember just it was one of those generic
sold sold a script you know but back to the
agent manager thing it's like you know they're
great to have but they they work you know
they only have so much resources to give you
you can't like rely on them for everything
even if they care and they they take the time
to read but they have 20 other clients so
you have to like really understand you know
what how to use them as well have a relationship
where because they their bottom they have
a bottom line you know they have to make money
too so a lot of people think oh i just want
an agent manager but you have to think what
are you providing them are you selling things
do you have things you can sell you know are
they going to take you on as a client and
build your career so where are you in the
process as well what do you provide for them
and so when you got those calls the next day
how did you know which person you wanted to
go with or or even entertain going with you
you have you have meetings and you meet with
them and then you kind of just decide you
know who's who's the correct person you know
based on based on instinct and and also to
um yeah chemistry and and also the manager
will kind of push you in that right direction
too we had a manager at the time and they
were like hey you know our manager said i've
got some other clients with with him and you
know so it's all very there's a lot of synergy
there when you got those calls and i'm assuming
it wasn't like you woke up and then your phone's
buzzing it's like one of those no it's not
like that hey jim this is so you know so but
how did were you like this is happening like
i've i've made it i mean it felt good to have
an agent but it felt good to have a manager
too but you quickly learned that like you
know you've got to do the work it's like okay
well you sold something that you know they
weren't part of so they didn't get commission
so they're like what's next you know and so
it's like you've got to get back on the treadmill
and start like figuring things out and doing
things.
Questions For The Viewers: How is this video
helpful to you?